Just like all the other problems, we're going to start by dividing each term by
our divisor, 6fg squared h. 3/6 Reduces to 1/2, so that's going to start my
answer. F cubed divided by f would leave me with f squared in the numerator, and
then g squared divided by g squared equals 1. And then h 4th divided by h equals
h cubed. Our second term would be 4fh squared, 24 divided by 6 equals 4 and f
squared divided by f makes f to the 1. The g squared divided by g squared
simplifies to 1 again, and then h cubed divided by h is equal to h squared. And
finally for our last term, we'll have negative 3 halves, f times h. F squared
divided by f is equal to f, and our g squared divided by g squared is equal to
1, so those simplify out. And finally, we have h squared, divided by h, which
leaves us with h to the 1. This first term and this last term, were a little
tricky, since we had fractions, but hopefully you got most of the variables
right. If you got everything right, excellent work.